well I think the most important
accomplishment we achieved was that we
could push European Union's trade
policies somewhat in direction of
increased openness I was personally able
to push through an abolishment of all
tariffs and all quotas on imports into
the European Union from the 49 poorest
countries in the world the least
developed countries according to the
United Nations definition and during
Sweden's presidency of the European
Union when I chaired the group of trade
ministers we were able to push through
this I think that was my single most
important contribution to global trade
otherwise it was the participation in
starting the dough around and pursuing
our negotiations but today I consider
that to be one of my failures not one of
my successes